there's a lot of interestingly shaped
people out here and you got to have your
heads on a swivel so you don't hit any
of them don't burn I'm doing another one
of these driving videos these how to how
to drive a little more courteous people
out there there's so much screaming and
yelling on Facebook would it be nice if
it stopped when you got on the road I'm
in I'm an Indianapolis Indiana home of
home of this downtown area I mean he was
kiddin know the [ __ ] pace has never
won anything did they they don't have a
hockey team they don't have a baseball
team Oh would you shut up ya [ __ ] know
I'm sorry me 200 that was very strong
it's very strong you interrupt me so
rudely anyways there's a downtown area
would you arrive at your destination on
the right you just can't have this
[ __ ] thing on some reason in downtown
Indianapolis we have enough lanes for
like a highway these [ __ ] things shut
up [ __ ] hate that navigation thing I
can't stand it and we're back in the day
just you just you had a map what was it
I know I sound like an old guy but you
could at least continue to listen to
your song pour some sugar on me back
then in the late 80s it always comes on
during the best part you know you're
totally in your fantasy you're playing
the guitar solo in front of everybody
who did you're wrong and they're like
wow we were really wrong about him and
then all the sudden it's like make a
left eye's here we go this is counting
down I had plenty of time to get through
the caution light so then yeah I make
that guy be first and I lose the people
behind us filming us it's tremendous
anyway this guy's staring hard at me
staring hard at me I hope he doesn't
have any [ __ ] issues with cameras
[ __ ] are you looking at good Lord they
not have cameras out here they never
filmed the [ __ ] episode of The Real
Housewives of Indianapolis you know with
them putting their horseshoes on the
bottom of those [ __ ] high heels
ah that's tells me that was me so
anyways if you notice I just made a nice
left turn there
I used my turn signal and then I sped up
a little bit so like this guy behind me
wouldn't get mad there's nothing wrong
with somebody coming into your lane as
long as you keep [ __ ] going
it's that [ __ ] will you come in and then
you step on the brakes like I'm not sure
how to do this very patriotic license
plates out here a lot of people out here
Indiana are very proud to be Americans
if you know what I mean the Klan is
strong in this state is all I'm saying
once again there's just no traffic
there's literally no traffic the second
you put these cameras on the car
everybody just takes up you saw with
that caught that guy was staring you saw
you staring by the way don't do that
when you're going up to an intersection
well up here on the right is the the
Alexander it's a big thing to do with
buildings and hotels now you do the Ohio
State thing when you put V in front of
it and then everybody's like oh [ __ ]
this must be special it really isn't
you know what you can never use when
you're in a hotel you can never use a
face cloth ever unless you're wiping
something up cuz like I am convinced
like like 40 loads a month I shot into
those goddamn things you know I guess
unless you're jerking off into one other
than that I keep it away from your face
yep
I'm just gonna rename these videos bill
cruises around while everybody stays in
their own length you know what I'm
realizing I think I've just been a
psycho and all this stuff I think that's
happening every five seconds actually
maybe happens once a drive you gotta
love a good bus station you know there's
sure there's a lot of degenerates down
there but there's always like a jewel or
something living in a locker getting
ready to sing another hit song oh well
say
whatever she say running another red
light cruising on through there you go
and the guy behind me made it our own
film crew want to speed up you want to
make the flight you want to get through
it I'm gonna ignore those people in the
wheelchairs oh just gliding through the
city as if there's no purpose for these
videos look at me I got my hand on the
wheel like this I'm leaning cutting over
nine lanes nobody beeping at me I'll
tell you one thing these people in
Indianapolis they [ __ ] work they get
to work and that's it or they're still
sleeping
is this a speed trap what's his feed
like 15 miles an hour oh it's a guy
could he's painting the line he's got to
do it himself he's got to push it out
it's adorable road closed shut the [ __ ]
up
whoa this is a lair she just said the
roads closed that's not close look at
this [ __ ] working out up there he's
doing burpees what is it with CrossFit
people that they can't just work out
thinking yeah everybody's got to know
you're working out it's like I work out
I do it inside goes up to the top of
this statue like he's in Rocky
Ben na alright so that was downtown
Indianapolis now you're supposed to get
up to speed here before you get over the
on-ramp is designed to get your speed up
in order to see people do on the highway
if you see that person that pulled over
to stop and then they're sitting in the
breakdown lane and they want to rejoin
people driving 70 miles an hour and they
put their blinker on and they just pull
out you got to get your speed up get up
to about 50 55 and then then you come
over it's all common sense right it all
makes sense to me who that giant stupid
Lucas Oil Field Stadium you know these
poor people here they're still paying
for it's still paying for the Hoosier
dump that cheatin bastard I'll tell you
one thing I would never be out here in
Indiana I'd never be a an uber driver I
mean there's literally nobody here this
level of people at so this is like what
this is what you dream about
there's cruise
all right this is getting a little weird
it's just people walking down the middle
of the street here we in the backwoods
now faster and Turkey shipped through a
tinhorn that look [ __ ] Rock I've
thought of snake was under it none of
these makes sense you know living in LA
this is just blows my mind
I forgot how just how green it can be
you know you ever flown across the
country from east coast to the west
coast it's like watching somebody's life
you know stalks off all beautiful lush
you know all the water that's like when
you're hastening a full head of hair
it's all shiny in the middle of the
country it kind of levels out that's
when you get married you having kids
just gonna do this I'm staying with you
the Rocky Mountains those are when you
get kidney stones then you get out to
the southwest and it's just all [ __ ]
get that first pain in your side right
it's perfect right near a graveyard and
all just goes [ __ ] right back down
again
right near the ocean I swear too much I
got to clean up my act
golly jakers I'm driving like a jerk
face